hey mr. wonderful here but I'm in the
kitchen so we don't need mr. wonderful
we need chef wonderful how are we gonna
get them eg well um but there's no chef
wonderful you know what I want to talk
about Mother's Day it's coming up and
this year it's gonna be very tough to
get flowers that's why the great people
love pop cards you remember that one of
my favorite shark tank companies these
kinds of cards I love them well they've
come up with bouquets look at these
beautiful flower bouquets ready for
Mother's Day and they ship in this
amazing container flat with its card you
can fill out for mom it's fantastic and
look at this these flowers fold right
back up you can store them and they're
never dead to me because you never have
to water them they're pieces of art
where do you get these love pop com
getting me for Mother's Day what a great
idea and they're just so beautiful oh my
goodness I just love this idea
innovation and I wanted to ask you about
your experience on Shark Tank let's
start there your perception of what that
show is about your journey into it and
what you actually learned from it I you
know I people ask me all the time about
what was it like being on shark tank and
what was interesting is I didn't I
hadn't watched a ton of shark tank when
I was first asked and I spent my
pregnancy and the first 12 weeks of my
daughter being born intensely watching
shark tank and part of the reason why I
decided to do it is that my head of
research told me you know she's
incredibly talented she's a PhD from
Stanford and a postdoc and she told me
she's like everything I ever learned
about business I learned from shark tank
and there was massive enthusiasm within
my company from a pretty you know
scientific crowd of like the impact that
shark tank has had on them so I decided
to do it for that reason and then I
became like a very dedicated student to
shark tank and watched I watched at
least three seasons like every single
season study
making notes and and I wanted to make
sure I was really prepared and everyone
I had talked to who'd been on Shark Tank
said you know that's your joining it's
kind of like joining someone else's prom
but you are new and you have to become
the prom queen that's true that's true
that is a good analogy actually but I'm
wondering all your you know that there's
because I've talked to many guests and
it's come on shark tank there's a
perception and then there's the you know
the casting process and you come and
visit the set then there's the miniature
in the chair and and I've always said
this to everybody the niceties are
wonderful shake your hand get to know
you smile at you but the minute those
cameras roll we don't really give a [ __ ]
about you anymore
and you're just a competitor and I and
we don't mean any disrespect by it but
it's I thought you were able to to get
into the groove pretty damn quickly so
for me it's actually almost the opposite
like I spend so much time thinking
through the scenarios in my head before
like I really like III have these
pictures of myself in labor like
watching shark tank and saying like no
no I'm being induced I'm gonna I'm gonna
what I'm gonna study so you spend a lot
of time thinking about like well what
would I say right now and so in some
ways my anticipation was far more
stressful than the moment I got in that
chair the moment I got in that chair I
was kind of like Shh what I'm over like
I've been studying this time for me that
that's everybody noticed that I think
it's fantastic
it was a very majority enjoyable
experience but but I'm always I always
ask this question to of guests were you
surprised at how long the pitches took
versus what you actually saw when you
were studying shark tank that's actually
I would say my biggest issue with with
the show I wanted I could have gotten
longer on the pitches I'm used to like
if I mean if I'm interviewing a company
it was a couple things like one I want
all the attention like I want them
dedicated to just my questions and I
want an hour of just my questions and so
the hardest thing that I had
is you guys all kept interrupting like
you all had your own set of questions
and oftentimes I was like that is not
relevant and so I wanted more time and
then you know you get the voice in your
ear are you in or you out
and so I I that was like the hub I was
like what I'm not done asking my
questions so it was actually like I said
I'm really um it went by fast
I was surprised like it's the fast
moving the hour that you have the
pitches it's fast moving it's intense
and you got all these different
questions and everyone's coming on it
from a different angle so um I mean I
loved it but it was just like the number
one thing for me is I kind of want you
all to shut up and so I could ask my own
questions well then I'll give you a
chance to speak out to the hundreds of
thousands of people now that have not
yet come into the shark tank set what
advice would you give an entrepreneur
that is going to stand in front of you
there after having gone through it
yourself and watching it occur what give
me give me some tips for them because
they're asking you now I'm not doing it
on their behalf I think the most
important thing I learned like I saw
there is you gotta be really succinct
with your story and your pitch like
what's the big picture how are you
different what's the opportunity and
then studying the Sharks to know
everyone has a hot spot and so you don't
want to touch some of those you don't
want to say I'm selling into China and
if I only get 1% then it's you know like
that clearly is a no-no for many of you
so I found sometimes that some people
they were they got so into the theatrics
which are fun that sometimes it was hard
to say like I want you to succinctly
tell me what exactly is your opportunity
so it's very it's very good advice and
do it right up front I get where you're
going with that because if you don't
catch your attention you're a shark you
brought money to the table it's never
gonna happen it's just never gonna
happen right and so I need to know also
that the person I'm giving money to like
knows how to effectively communicate
their idea in
efficient way like as a leader you need
someone who's like direct to the point
who knows how to communicate to all
their employees to the investors to the
world what it is that they're doing and
so that was the thing like sometimes you
get some really great theatrics but I
need like to concisely know exactly what
is going on here let's let's pivot I
want to talk to you about your business
23andme which has become a very
successful business you're not really
selling DNA kits are you that's not your
business
the goal for like my my original like I
I'm a huge believer in founders who are
solving their own problems so I came to
23andme
with 10 years of experience on Wall
Street saying I'm putting you know
hundreds of millions of dollars to work
in a system that I think is relatively
dysfunctional for all of us I don't
think the health care system represents
what's in the best interest of us
meaning that it's focused really on
treatments and not on keeping you
healthy and then secondly if you do get
sick the biotech industry is the only
thing that reminds me of communism
we're in communist society you would
talk about how your costs all the time
and how they keep going up biotech is
the only industry I know where they say
every single year were worse at what we
do when I started investing it was only
seven hundred million dollars to make a
drug and now it's two billion dollars to
make a drug and so I took looked at that
and I said fundamentally we have a
problem with how we're approaching this
and part of the issue is that you have
all these siloed labs working on a part
of the problem but you need to put all
those pieces together and so the most
important thing I said is like we all
collectively we all care about staying
healthier like if I go and I survey all
the people with rheumatoid arthritis or
multiple sclerosis or HIV like they all
come together and they all would love to
see a cure so instead of having all
these little tiny silos
let's bring the people together on a
platform and let's empower them to be
part of research
to find Prevention's and cures if I have
a consumer that's never heard of 23andme
what is the value proposition in the
shark tank mode that you're pitching me
that I should actually go through the
process that you're offering me to buy
your service what's the pitch 23 me is
all about learning your genetic
information that is gonna tell you about
your genetic ancestry and it's going to
give you a path for your disease risks
and how you can live a healthier life I
think that says it in a nutshell and how
many people do you think never do it
because they're just scared to get that
information I think you know when we
first started when we first started a
company we saw there's probably you know
single digit percentages 5% that just
never wanted to be online I think now
there's worry understandably like
worried about how is all your
information being used so that said over
80% of my 12 plus million customers have
opted in to research and so we we've
been able to show that if you're
transparent with people about how your
information is being used people want it
used you just want the transparency so
one thing I am really proud of with 23
me is we've always said the most
important thing that we can do is be
transparent because we have your genetic
information it's incredibly sensitive
information about you that we want to
empower you with but we also want to
empower you to make these discoveries
that are ultimately in my opinion gonna
change your lives how do you deal with
the debate when Akkineni constituency or
any constituent asks you look in you
you're get I want your service I'm
willing to pay for it now you have my
DNA information my fingerprint that
makes me unique globally and then the
police subpoena you for it what's the
answer to that we've we we we we do not
work with the police on any of these we
have been successfully been able to
fight all of our any kind of subpoena
that's coming away so it's never been a
case where they're trying to solve a
murder trial in San Francisco they use
you to solve it no no we we do not we
have a transparency report on our
website we
are not working with the police or any
kind of crime groups at all and one
thing also who is that if you spit you
know I can have mr. wonderful in 23 me
you have the ability to get any time to
delete your account including the
information including the DNA and people
ask about like do you really do that and
let me tell you we spend a lot of time
in the company making sure that we can
honor people's requests about what they
want to do with their data that's good
to know and another question obviously
we're living in unusual times I'm going
to guess that your office is abiding by
the Canyon California rules and
everybody's working from home is that
the case
correct yes okay so now here's my
question as the week's roll on and your
efficiency remains the same I'm going to
assume that probably you haven't really
been hurt that badly sales-wise as
people are sitting around at home
thinking of things to do with themselves
I'm guessing here but here's my question
as an investor one of the biggest asset
classes I have on my balance sheet is
real estate I own REITs I have
commercial real estate I have you know
pieces of office towers all that stuff
and I'm looking at all my companies over
50 of them that I'm a significant
investor in in my portfolio of small
businesses and asking each CEO as I talk
to them every day as they're trying to
solve our problems as some are doing
it's exceptionally well because they
have sanitization products like a blue
land or or you know anybody that's
servicing home gyms or anything like
that they're doing great and the ones
that are in the restaurant business are
dying and all the rest of it it's
volatile but everybody's figuring out
that they're able to run a business
without going to the office I know and
I'm asking myself as an you know in my
companies I'm telling everybody guys why
do we need to spend twenty five thousand
a month on office rent why don't we do a
nip nip nip chop-chop-chop when this is
over and figure out what are the
essential office attendees and yeah what
do you think is that gonna be a problem
you know I've been thinking about like I
think the most interesting thing that's
going on right now is it's gonna
dramatically shift it's gonna change the
world it's gonna change everything and I
think the areas is going to change
you know how people work and also it's
gonna change digital health so I think
it's very clear that people are able to
see that you know how they work from
home they can actually be quite
effective I actually like I was looking
at the we work news today in terms of
that investment it made me think like do
I need an office space or do I just need
sort of a space that I can congregate
two days a week because I think there is
a value for actually having people come
in periodically but I have been
incredibly productive just being at home
I mean well I'm more productive because
I've gone into this crazy cycle with
virtual assistants some in Europe and
some I'll give you an example I shot an
interview like similar to this with
Maria shapoval
Sharapova last week and normally I would
go into an edit suite in New York with
editors and I would tell them I
recounted the interview I'm doing with
you just like like this and and they
would cut it they would they would edit
it the way that I envisioned the thing
would be and we'd use a beautiful
console and all of the equipment and I
don't have any thousand dollars an hour
I don't even know now there are virtual
editors one is sitting in in France and
the other one is in LA yeah and and I'm
saving thousands of dollars and they're
so time shifted that hey I got up at 3
o'clock and I cut for an hour with them
we'll think about I mean think about
also cuz you own a lot of real estate
you know one of the biggest challenges I
have here is recruiting talent to the
Bay Area and how expensive it is but if
I can find amazing talent and they can
live in lower cost areas potentially
like really helps my recruiting and they
can they can be remote so but that
that's gonna chip that's gonna change
the way you think of running your
business so I would think my point is
will there be permanent impairments to
things like I'll give you another
example my favorite restaurant in New
York is in the inner basement it's
packed it's jam-packed I'm sitting like
this besides other people I don't know
am I gonna do that again anytime soon I
don't think so I'm going full Howie
Mandel I'm going I'm
like I'm I'm not feeling I don't want to
be jammed in with a bunch of people in
on it and and so does that permanently
impaired certain businesses as
behavioral change gets enforced over
these weeks and then months until this
thing gets resolved I I think it I think
it does I mean I think that you will
have like my child was just my 11 year
old was asking me he's like am I gonna
be known as a cranial like am I like the
child of the corona virus occur oniel
and my child a corona virus where
there's gonna be life before and then
there's life after and the world really
dramatically changes and I remember this
from 9/11 how much there was sort of
that that that point in time where the
world really shifted and I think like I
said I think the areas that I see most
most clearly is how people work and the
effectiveness of zoom the effectiveness
of remote working and actually the
productivity bump that we get from
working from home so I think there's
potentially a bump in and how effective
people can be and the other thing that's
again near and dear to my heart is
telemedicine digital health you cannot
go to a doctor like right now people
like if you have an issue like I had you
know I had a dermatology question I just
email my dermatologist but there was no
way she was gonna let me come in so
everyone has to be you can use your
phone I took a picture of my mole I send
my dermatologists you are going everyone
who questioned the idea of digital
health is being forced right now to
adopt it and I think that you see how
quickly the FDA is moving like the
policy changes that have happened that
we talked about wanting to have that we
anticipated we're gonna take five plus
years happened in a week you're right
it's an excellent observation that will
be a nascent sector that explodes
because you're right I could think my
last doctor visit to Boston was a couple
of days ago digitally with that doctor
asking some questions I was riding my
bike and it written it sliced my ankle
pretty badly and I showed it to him said
do I need stitches or not and normally I
would have gone in right so there's a
couple like I'm an investor in a company
called doctors on demand
and the CEO was saying like I am the
country's emergency room right now I'm
the emergency room in the country and
it's exploded and then this other
company that I love it's this little
tiny thermometer a company and in some
ways this is so basic but it's a
thermometer with you know essentially
GPS and and sends information but it's
the ones called Kenza and it's been
sending information about where all the
fevers are that's fat that's fascinating
so that's an add-on to your phone I
guess right it's an app no it's just you
don't they do anything yeah well you
take it and it plug it has an app that
matches with your phone but then it's
also really convenient well my kids are
sick I can just track and see what their
temperatures are and I know every time
and it tracks your medications so but
technology like that is gonna
fundamentally change like healthcare so
I think healthcare like I like there's
so much doom and gloom out there but
like the pitch I have given to my
employees is that like the world is
definitely like there's a lot of pain
out there right now but when you have
this pain it's an opportunity for change
so think about like where do we want to
be in two years time think about like
all this pain that we're feeling and how
is that gonna force change and use the
time while you're at home to be creative
because it's this incredible luxury
where I'm actually alone like I get time
to like I get time to do yoga in to
meditate and like to actually think a
little bit more because I'm not
commuting and I have less meetings but
think about like where's the world gonna
go and how do we build towards that
speaking of that is a great segue to
this question in the last financial
crisis Oh ate a new asset class emerge
our new service in IndieGoGo and
Kickstarter if you remember because the
entrepreneurial space was shut down by
the since they couldn't find anything
there was no VCS willing to put capital
out and so out of necessity those
platforms were born and they grew very
large but it wasn't it was a different
form of funding because you basically
financed the prototype and then
eventually the first run of the product
I'm going to speculate and I want your
opinion on this that right now the VC
community is is really hunkered down
it's really hard to get a deal done or
even again
meaning and they're worried about their
portfolios plenty of many of which might
go to zero we don't know but there's a
new form of financing emerging I've been
doing a lot of due diligence on it
finally made a decision in terms of
investment recently I've been watching
the equity crowdfunding market emerge
where a start-up says I have an idea I
want to raise a million dollars
traditionally you'd go to a VC that you
know probably and say I need a million
against the five million pre value I'm
gonna sell twenty thirty percent of my
company to a concentrated shareholder
it's great to have a branded VC and all
that now you can go raise a million
bucks on a Saturday on a equity
crowdfunding platform and and you have
10,000 shareholders that have small
amounts of dollars in it I've been
watching this and that the biggest one
that that has I guess it's one the the
critical mass race is start engine
Howard Marx the co-founder of Activision
put it together and I was gonna compete
with him and said no he beat me so I'm
just gonna buy a piece of his company
and join forces which is what I've done
what do you think about that platform
what do you thinks gonna happen coming
out of this do you think a lot of
entrepreneurs are gonna discover that
asset class and start using it instead
of the traditional VC interesting
question I think I mean I think one of
the things that's change is you have a
lot of wealthy individuals who have
angel funds and you're gonna have
platforms like this that are going to
crowdsource equity and I do think you
have a lot of venture capital firms that
are like that do need to protect their
existing investments so I absolutely
think that there's you know a way of
getting these off the ground you know
the thing I would think about again I
haven't looked at a lot of these
platforms is you know some of the legal
aspects like when you have more than
certain number of shareholders then the
disclosures and the publicity and what
you have to do so one advantage of
having a smaller group of investors is
the secrecy well I see that but the SEC
actually created this and wanted it
intended to create it using the JOBS Act
it's just that nobody had got enough the
critical mass ended up being
success factor was how many investors
can you investors can you apply and get
on your platform
Howard beat everybody he got 250,000
investors on his platform and he beat
everybody that's what happened because
it's hard to get them but those
disclosure metrics are very simple you
have a shelf prospectus sewn it's very
easy now and it works I'm fascinated by
it because I've been a you know private
equity guy for my whole investment life
and recently got beat out by one of
these platforms and I waited I thought I
mean look I think I think competition to
the old school again it's a little bit
like it's the institutional VCS are
facing competition and all of these
platforms that essentially flatten
access I think are are gonna empowering
and enable a lot of new ideas that
otherwise VCS wouldn't necessarily get
you know wouldn't necessarily always
fund and is gonna enable these you know
it's gonna have enable competition well
let them sing for their supper I've got
a set of questions from around the world
we're gonna take a journey around the
world
for you and this is kind of like the
lightning round so just give me a minute
to get on the server and pull them down
I think you're gonna find some very
interesting ones here let's see the
first one here looks like it is Kelsey
all right let's hear from Kelsey hi mr.
wonderful my name is Kelsey and I'm 27
years old I've just really started
diving into my career and I'm very
career-focused right now however a lot
of my friends family loved ones are
trying to push me into marriage and
starting a family and everywhere I look
people are getting married having kids
that whole sort of thing and that's just
not really where I see my life going I'm
getting a lot of pushback from people
saying that this is the time that I
should be focused on that but I just
don't see that where my source of
happiness is and where I want my life to
go should I let those comments deter me
in any way does being career-focused
mean that there's something wrong with
me I would love to hear your insight on
this
thank you so much for everything I
really really look up to you and hope to
hear from you
so Ann honey sweetie poopsie this is for
you what is the answer I so I I tell my
kids all the time that one of my
superpowers is ignoring people and I
love getting feedback I love I love
hearing advice I love like my mom is
full of advice and my siblings and I
mean the world the world is constantly
giving you feedback but um you know the
one thing I've learned especially as
I've gotten older is that it's your life
and what is right for you is not
necessarily what's right for others and
I can say when I decided I was gonna
have my third child on my own a lot of
people thought I was crazy and I
remember actually back in in 1991 I
deferred college for a year back when it
was not common to take a gap year and I
remember one of my friend's parents
yelling at me saying I was gonna ruin my
life
and you know part of again what I've
learned to do is like it's ultimately
it's my life and what works for me is
not necessary what works for others and
I love getting the feedback I love
understanding where they're coming from
and you know in this case it's it's
great to think about like do you want to
have children it's great to have like a
premeditated decision like no I do not
want to have this right now these are
the way this is how I'm thinking about
it and then it's ultimately it's your
life and you know Diane von Furstenberg
is the one she has the the in charge
movement and I love it and ultimately I
think about every single day like it's
nothing greater than being an adult and
being in charge of your life so
basically or your advice is [ __ ] it it's
your life do you do what you think is
right tough to say that to 27 year old
because there's so much uncertainty in
their outcome right but I think it's I
think I've always pitched so long as
when it comes to career I've always
pitched people like do things that push
you to keep learning if you're suddenly
bored and a job don't just stay in a job
because the right thing for you
çb keep learning and if you don't want
to have kids right then and you don't
want to get married like my god don't
like absolutely like you can have kids
later and i think i have seen you know
it's you know sometimes people marry and
they have children sometimes you can
have them on your own but I think you
need to think about and you've done
you've done both is one better than the
other I think that it's again both both
I love all my children but it is you
know there's pros and cons for being
married and I see I have some friends
who are incredibly happily married and I
have some friends who are not and the
way my life unfolded is that if I wanted
to have more kids I had to have one
alone and I'm really happy like I'm glad
to hear that because ultimately you want
to be you want to live your life happy
there's no question let's move on we're
gonna hear from let's try
okay let's try Suzanne where's she phone
hi mr. wonderful this is Suzanne from
the Philippines and I want to ask how do
you know when it's time to close a
business when do you quit a business
that might be having a hard time or when
do you figure out you know it's just a
challenging time in the business and you
need to continue it you just need to
find new solutions for the challenges
you're facing thank you
okay and when you take it behind the
barn and shoot it come on you know this
how long do you give a startup before
you just know it's not gonna work when
do you tell you what how do you I mean
if you're gonna give me the come by I
answer you never give up yada yada yada
there comes a point where it doesn't I
mean I think it it's a hard question
because there's not a definitive answer
and I've seen lots of lots of times
where you think you know something is
going to fail and then suddenly it turns
a corner that's very hopeful but it
doesn't happen very often it doesn't
happen very often
I
I think the reality this isn't it this
is an example thinking even on the other
question where sometimes individuals
lack perspective like sometimes you're
the person running this this is an
opportunity to get outside advice
because sometimes Outsiders will put in
should be able to see the potential or
the lack of potential better than than
you so this is one thing I think about a
lot is you know getting that external
opinions and there are some businesses
that are not meant to succeed and if you
have if you just every so often you come
up with an idea and it's too early or
you don't see the market reacting and
you cannot be profitable within a period
of time you have to kill it so I would
say the advice I would almost give is
like you put a time stamp on how long
you want it to run before you're
actually gonna be sustainable and if you
don't hit that then you kill it how do
you like how do you like three years as
a time frame how do you like three years
to determine half the profitability or
at least find a way to acquire customers
profitably do you think that's a
reasonable time frame I think it's
reasonable but I think it's also very
dependent on each business well I'll
just let you in on a secret if I invest
in a company as a start-up and I take a
major position in it more than 40% and I
tell them when we start if you can't
figure this out in three years I'm
taking it behind the barn and shooting
it and I'm putting putting provisions in
for that because I want you to
understand
I'll keep funding until it's clear that
this idea doesn't have merit and I think
I mean that's what maybe you think
that's arbitrary but that's what I do I
think three years is almost generous for
some businesses good I'm glad to hear
that I don't feel as bad because I have
a lot of people whining in the second
yeah after they get past the second year
they still haven't if you're not showing
and I tell this to in my company - cuz
we're not profitable now like I said
you're either growing or you're
profitable
well you're growing like a weed right we
are right in the market the market
definitely turned on us last year so we
have we have two aspects of our business
is the consumer side which definitely
shrank and is also has been hit back hit
by the by coronavirus but secondly we
are exploding on the drug development
side so being able to look at all of our
data and say I'm gonna look at you know
people with you know with multiple
sclerosis and you've got the data set
you've got the data right we have we
have an incredible opportunity in making
therapies but part of the issue is drug
discovery is very expensive I became a
large shareholder in a company called
mine med recently and I'm learning very
quickly how valuable data is in that
business we're trying to determine the
the effectiveness of micro dosing
psychedelics and we're getting some very
interesting data and and we are the
first to I took that company public
along with it's it's it's Board of
Directors a couple of weeks ago and
we've just acquired a whole bunch of
data from Basel Switzerland the
birthplace of LSD but what I've realized
that the whole value the market cap is
determined on data the data we have that
no one else has on these clinical trials
Stage two I think you're going to be
shocked and at the effectiveness on
things like depression anxiety
alcoholism drug addiction on the power
of these psychedelics that were shut
down in the 60s because they thought
they were just you know recreational
drugs this company is not doing anything
recreational but I'm a very excited
about that one but it rings true with me
what you're saying the value of 23andme
now maybe it's data which brings me to
another question regarding that is what
kind of drift off for the questions but
when are you gonna merge with ancestry
that makes so much sense I mean if I
were an investor in both I just I'd get
you two together on a zoom call I mean
don't you see the synergies ya know we
see them we see them quite a bit oh
there's a tremendous amount of synergy
you'd be profitable like that I know you
know that's what things it's it's um you
know it's almost like parents can see
the the match made in heaven but
sometimes the kids it takes you know you
got to figure out you actually dates
well you know I am sure based on you
know I mean I I'm sure both sides can
see the opportunity and I love to I love
to be a mansion a [ __ ] disturber but for
me for me that is such a such a
fantastic combo and it's a lot I mean I
think it's it's amazing because people
want to do a lot with their DNA and so
clearly there's more you can you learn
about your ancestry and then you want to
go and explore records we've taken more
of the pitch that you learn about your
DNA and I put you on this path to be
healthier and health is a sum of what
you've done every single day of your
life you know it's not like you change
your behavior today and suddenly you're
like how Louie I'm healthy so part of
what we're trying to do is is really go
deep on the health side of saying I'm
willing to make a bet that by giving you
your genetic information I'm actually
going to change the curves and I'm gonna
make you healthier I totally get it but
some some things are decreed by the
power of the force and this is one of
them so I'm just putting that in your
ear well if I need a bank rocking higher
you Kevin yeah wonderful can work
something I'm pretty good at that all
right let's let's listen to Henry here
what does he got
hello mr. wonderful I hope you're having
a good day and you're stayin safe out
there my name is Henry and I would like
to ask you a hopefully simple question
how do I determine the price for my
product I have a product that I'm hoping
to launch within the next 60 days
hopefully less and I don't know the
right price for my product where I could
maximize my profit margin I should also
say that I do not have a huge bank
account to spend on research and all
those things
in fact like most people in my position
I put most of my money to creating this
product if you can share some advice I
would really be eternally thankful thank
you so much and you have a good thing in
a nutshell and he's asking how do you
determine the price when you're
launching a new product you've had to do
this
we do it all the time you have to do
research we will introduce prices to
different sets we will take a group of
individuals that come from different
economic backgrounds and different
ethnic backgrounds and roll out
different prices to them and we look at
the data about what is the price where
you're gonna get the most volume or the
most maximizing contribution so volume
you know you don't want to just you know
you need to maximize the contribution
margin meaning like I need to how much
volume can I get for the best margins so
you are you geo locking those offers to
different geographies we will do it in
different geographies and to different
in different yeah we can do some of
these there's all kinds of platforms I
don't know the specific names of them
but there's platforms that we use online
we don't necessarily test it through
Facebook but there's different platforms
that we can that we can do testing on I
mean I think in the in the case of like
as a start-up you know in the early days
where we didn't have a budget to do it
we just like honestly I would sit in
front of Safeway and just ask people and
so it's not potentially gonna be less
scientific but there's some of those
rogue tactics that you do when you have
to be scrappy and don't have the ability
to do it or you know post on Craigslist
that you know pay people some-some
dollar amount for that feedback so I
think that there's a ways to potentially
get scrappy information or just roll it
out at different time points and again
depending on what the product is
different prices and see what the volume
is as pricing ever surprised you
assumptions you've made about you know
most people say ah the magic price point
999 1999 2000 as pricing ever surprise
we so we we actually did our Series C
entirely based on pricing where 23andme
in the early days we were priced at
it was 199 or $2.99 and we sold less
than 20 to 30 kids a day and we decided
that on this made-up holiday DNA day we
were gonna discount the price to $99 and
I remember at 7:00 in the morning my
head engineer called me and he's like
and we sold we put a limited a thousand
kits and we hit it already what should
we do when I was like I don't know just
let it run and this back in the day I
was like oh whatever
and by 4 o'clock in the afternoon we had
sold 17,000 kits and it only later
occurred to me I was like holy cow this
is a supply chain nightmare like do I
have this number of kids like all these
issues but it showed to me that there
was clearly demand and that price was a
huge bottleneck and so it's part of
where I said like I didn't have to pay
any kind of expensive study we just
changed the price for a day and we saw
what the demand is and that's one of the
things that we do like you see us now on
prime day and on you know DNA day we
will discount and you get massive volume
for some of these discounts I have a
similar story you might find interesting
because it was a real it was a real
stressful moment for me I got a phone
call years ago and I was part of the
learning company and the standard price
for read Arab and Carmen Sandiego and
all that stuff was 39.95 and we sold
half a billion dollars worth of it and
then the price point of PCs dropped to
999 dollars when Walmart decided to
start selling pcs so I got a phone call
from the buyer he said I want I want to
meet you personally like I know you're
you know I want you to come here and I
have an offer for you but I need I don't
want you sales guy I want you so I went
there and I and he said hi I'm the buyer
I last week I I sold the fishing boot
category which is very big for us in
Walmart now I'm the software guy I said
okay well I am I here he said I want to
sell read a rabbit for $14.99 and I said
well we can't because that's the price
we sell it to you for and then you sell
between
said no I want to buy it from you for
$5.00 and 20 cents and I'd like to order
12 million cents
and just so you know your competitor is
outside in the hall you're the category
leader so we always give you the
multiple SKUs first if your answer's no
I have no problem with him but he's
right outside just see him as you leave
didn't have a chance to call the board
or anything took the deal
Wow never look back because he knew
something I didn't know the demand would
explode for reading out guys for test
scores when when when everybody American
before to PC Neverland we grew by 40%
and we put out a lot of competitors out
of business because we skilled that was
a year that the bad Alba came out by
Michael Jackson and we tell every press
in the world he had to delay the bat
release it bad for two weeks because
arena rep I'm proud of this wow that's
amazing I mean I got that's where like I
said I think pricing like one of the
strategies that we've had is that it's
really it get the part of the goal of 23
me is research and so I was focused on
driving volume and if you're focused on
driving volume then it was really
important for me to say I need to I'm
gonna cut down the price and so much ins
name you must be very very sensitive
versus price by now been doing it for
years we have been doing your ears and
we've tried all kinds of different
pricing and we can see at different
holidays and and against their
seasonality for us like people never
would have expected like where were
registered medical device with the FDA
and we do a massive amount of volume
that Christmas so it is it's it's a it's
a gift and that was actually one of the
things also that was not sort
anticipated is that this is something
that people give on Mother's Day
Father's Day graduation presents
birthday presents and for holidays again
another reason why you gotta merge with
ancestry well chat but I think it I
thing is really like I said it's one of
those underappreciated arts I totally
get it cuz I've learned
I've learned from my own experience
let's just
hi mr. wonderful this is Brooke my
question for you is as I'm currently in
my second year of university studying
and being involved in a bunch of
extracurricular I'm afraid that I don't
have enough time to fully start my own
online company but I really want to do
you think I should wait until after
graduation which by then I would have
gained all my knowledge from my
undergrad degree and also some
experience from coops to then start it
or should I start right now well I am
craving for financial freedom I said I
think if you have a great idea you
should pursue it well you're you're cool
with it just puts more pressure on her I
mean think about that
I think there's ways to I'm I'm a very
effective multitasker so it's hard for
me sometimes to not everyone is but
there's ways to try it you know and at
least researching the idea whether you
have to go all-in versus you know trying
things like you look at Sara Blakely and
how she first you know you try it you
experiment and the first couple years of
any startup is a lot of experimentation
so you know something about being in
college that is you have a great testing
ground right there I think the
strategies you go to Professor and what
are your entrepreneurial or business
classes to say look I'd like you to
grade me on my ability to start this
business well I'm here now I mean maybe
that's how you allocate some time and
you actually get graded on they do the
research or whatever I want to end on a
topic that you know we all deal with and
I'd like to hear your opinion on it this
is about families but family you have a
very you know open view obviously you're
raising you've got a great compound
you're raising your family there that's
wonderful you're financially free that's
a great thing you deserve it you did it
yourself what do you think the modern
family looks like
coming out of this and and I have some
eggs myself and speaking entrepreneurs
now what to do with children I'm not
sure I want to give my kids a tremendous
amount of wealth I'm not sure that's a
good outcome for what's your plan I'm a
huge believer in not I tell my kids I
was like I'm a huge believer making you
suffer so I and I like tell them like
you're not when you go to when you leave
the house like you will get nothing like
you need to learn how to be scrappy so
part of what we're doing in this
quarantine is you know how do you make a
bed like why do you have a duvet cover
how do you clean the bathroom
and I think that you know I didn't grow
up with money and I same time I grew up
near Palo Alto so I saw people who had
money and I always found that there was
this incredible creativity when you have
constraints and you don't have cash and
my roommate in college for instance you
grew up you know with no money at all
and quite before was the most creative
person I knew and I think that there's
something really beautiful that comes
from not having easy access to capital
the struggle and I think also like you
mentioned like I I have money now and
I'm free but actually to me it's not the
money that makes me free it's the
ability to know how to live without
money so like the first year I lived in
New York I earned $40,000 a year and I
was determined that I I knew I would
never make that much money again and so
I needed to save $1,000 a month so I
gave myself $15 a week to spend and I
took the leftover food from the Yale
Club like I walked a hundred and 20
blocks every day I you know went to any
free dinner invite like I learned I knew
how to save I knew when there was you
know squash on sale twelve for a dollar
I bought it I would like bought it out
like I knew I know how to live on
nothing
and there's freedom is not necessarily
the freedom that comes by having a lot
of money the freedom comes by knowing
how to manage your expenses and and and
knowing then like to do the things that
you want to do in a very limited budget
so I'm a huge believer like the kids
will not get like I will pay for school
I'll help them as as needed but they
really need to struggle because beauty
comes from that struggle Ashley give me
two ideas for books for our viewers what
do you like to read right now what's on
your mind
oh I I just had my my son I've been
reading some books with him he just read
the Henrietta Lacks book which was about
in part I'm having a really good time
with my son is having this little book
club with him and and and and for me
it's like thinking about like ethical
issues in research and and the
importance of transparency because
people are worried about privacy and for
those of you who don't know the
Henrietta Lacks story it was a story of
somebody who is sick they took her her
cells her tumor cells and they used them
in research very widely today and for me
one of the most important things as we
are having a data economy is that people
understand how their information is
being used so transparency is really key
the second book now that I'm reading
with my son is an oldie but a favorite
is Tuesdays with Maurey yes because I
think that again as this time that we're
sitting at home and you have an
opportunity to be more reflective it's
kind of about and it almost goes with
that first question we had how do you
want to live your life and there's an
opportunity while we're gonna be
quarantined for the next at least four
weeks to think about like how is this
making you rethink everything and how do
you want to live your life and when you
are at that point in your life where
you're on your deathbed are you looking
back and do you feel like you missed out
on anything and I always have what ever
since I read that book in high school
I've always started at that point and
then I make sure that everything I'm
doing like I'm going to be
happy when I'm you know fortunate to be
you know a hundred years old and and and
ill then but I want to make sure I don't
have any regrets and so thinking about
that and they want my kids like they're
at this lovely young age now where they
can think about like what kind of life
do they want what do they dream about
listen we've had a great time today I've
really enjoyed your insights and I'm
sure if yours did to particularly some
of those insights on these questions a
little tricky but you seem to call it
like it is I like that I try I hope to
see you back on the shark king set
you're a hero it was you know and you're
a meanie you're just actually I almost
sent you a picture because I had my
potato with my face on it for a long
time and then it finally started
sprouting and so I put it in the compost
and I almost send you a picture of my
lovely potato with my face potato those
things just keep going and now it's
strained with the demand because there's
another business that you know people
want to send something to make someone
else feel better whether it's a cupcake
or potato or you know whatever it's so
amazed that which businesses got
affected adversely versus the ones that
have just exploded and yeah it would
have been easy to guess but we've been
wrong in multiple cases and and I'm
spending a tremendous amount of time
working with my entrepreneurs to get
through this I just ended alone so what
am i companies in Oklahoma because
they're Bank Assurance mmm they can't
even go arrange for the government
assisted programs I know what you know
and they have a fantastic business so
it's crazy it's a remarkable time but
anyways look it's been absolutely great
it's been great and I just have to say
one more thing my son like I said this
on the show my son really wanted me to
do a deal with you so anytime you want
to sell part of your potato you screwed
me over so many times I'm going to talk
to your mother's just really we'll make
it happen at some point we want it we
want to be in with you on something
think about the trouble we could cause
you you had another interview idea for
me
that Oh actually Seth um South Berkeley
he went you know him I don't know but I
know yes yeah
Seth is he's a an old friend who I guess
a very eloquent charming and I think it
would be an important interview in this
time I'm having so much fun doing this
given you know I kind of sleep for hours
that I worked four hours sleep four
hours it's a whole new way of living I
and I've learned the time-shifting is
very cool yeah if this is gonna it goes
back to what we started this is gonna
change so much change so much what the
other person they'll be interesting is
Michael Specter who is a writer for The
New Yorker yeah so he lives out here now
we see him often but he wrote a bunch of
books just on on this concept that
people you know people don't believe a
lot of science experts people would
rather believe Gwyneth Paltrow then you
know Falchi so so it's an interesting
moment in time like why is it that the
scientists have lost a lot of
credibility so he's he looks at a lot of
that which is also interesting you know
around climate change
I can't believe is the Paris Accord and
how that whole mandate is basically
falling apart well in some ways
I mean look what's happened now with
climate change like the weather is
lovely and we whether we liked it or not
we've been forced to absolutely cut our
consumption yeah that's true I wanted to
ask you just your personal opinion on I
am I'm pretty after after interviewing
and then doing the off-camera stuff with
with David Kennedy the doctor and Martin
Solomon it's very troubling the sweat
market stuff like it's a social norm
though and it's a historical one in many
cultures but I feeling like speaking out
against it because it's caused a lot of
grief both economic and in on human life
you can't eat a bad head you just can't
do it right and I think it should be
globally acknowledged and we should
modify as a human race yeah about that
am I gonna get myself in love no I think
it's I think it's worth having it that
disk
rushon as to where these pandemics come
from pandemic risk comes from and
clearly the economic consequences from
this one are massive and if we can go to
the root of the cause I think it's
important for us to say we need to go to
the ROO the cause a lot of aspects of
society have had to change because it's
in the best interest of the entire
population there is a route and there is
a cause and when you eat species that
you shouldn't this is what happens and
you can't contain it in your borders and
I don't want to focus on one society or
one country but it should be coming
legally globally it should be a mandate
just like war there's certain things you
have agreed to and I think I'm gonna
make it one of my pitches and causes
because I'm pretty unhappy this keeps
happening to us over and over again
for one singular reason I think you look
at it is not like anything that is has
the risk of causing a global pandemic we
need to reduce or cut out yeah and I
clearly the wet markets are an important
contributor to pandemic risk and so we
need to reevaluate those so I that's the
kind of thing would be really
interesting if you chatted with
separately or Michael Specter about like
bringing in the scientists who are
really looking at those what kind of
impact would that have on the world
yeah thank you your insight on that
because you're looking at this from a
data basis but anyways give me a call
when you start your negotiations with
ancestry I don't give you any no well I
can't wait
hopefully your fees are low oh it's so
expensive you know I know you're not
giving your son any money I will after I
get my fees on that he might join you
he's a good negotiator learning how to
argue non-stop I had a lot of fun thank
you take care yeah you too thanks mr.
wonderful
Annie Beach lockdown I have to get out
take a cruise on my viva la bike it's
beautiful just got it
I need to get out once in a while like
anybody else and I just thought this
would be a great way to celebrate a
little freedom on a bicycle custom made
online I love what these guys did now
I'm not a paid spokesperson I bought
this bike they're not asking me to do
this
I'm just doing a shout out for a great
bunch of entrepreneurs everyone said
well you got to do that I love this
thing
go online talk to Stan the man that's
what I did on Facebook design my own
bike
add a little certain junus a quad to it
now I'm cycling around getting a little
exercise in the Miami Sun for who stay
safe everybody bye bye